et can confirm a Playboy founder Hugh
Hefner has died
are you talking to a human being here
who is enjoying life and enjoys his work
very much but also enjoys the other
parts of his life a self-made
millionaire with a lavish lifestyle
he was often spotted in his iconic red
robe with a pipe in hand surrounded by
gorgeous women how do you think you're
perceived well I know that there was a
tremendous amount of curiosity about me
and my lifestyle cetera and that is not
altogether an accident but I also think
that it has a major part to do with what
playboy is all about I think that the
two great fascinations and gilts in
America are sex and wealth and in
combining the truth in Playboy and then
with my own lifestyle so intimately
related to the magazine I think it's
very natural that people both have a
great fascination about back and about
me and also the source of their
contribution after founded Playboy
magazine in 1953 partly from a $1,000
loan from his mother I believe in the
things I'm doing I believe in Playboy I
believe in the things that we've
attempted to do through the magazine and
through the Playboy Foundation they are
important to me
[Music]
you